Gertrude Gee Gee Gee Michaelson 1947
columbia law school I went to the law
school not with the intention of
practicing law I went to get older and
smarter Columbia had a long history of
admitting women I have a recollection of
one of the distinguished members of the
faculty look my saddle shoes with
considerable disdain but I felt
comfortable before the wonderful
building that the law school is in now
we were in the venerable Kent hall I met
my husband at Columbia Law School he had
come to the law school after 40 months
in combat in the Pacific he was the
smartest boy in the class which was
helpful for me that's for sure we were
seated alphabetically so when I married
I was rearranged and receded with thee
with the m's so I had a whole new
cluster of friends when Oh Michael
sovereign who was at one time the dean
of the law school became the president
of the University I was his first
trustee and that gave me exposure to the
broader University and I ultimately
became chairman of the board of trustees
my election to the chair got a lot of
publicity because it was the first time
a woman had chaired the board of an Ivy
League institution I didn't feel it was
so singular but apparently the rest of
the world Watsa we decided that the
college would become co-ed and that was
a monumental decision so I'm really
proud that that happened on my
I had marched at the commencement for
many years I find it particularly moving
to see first generation parents of kids
who are graduating where the parents
have not had that opportunity I find it
emotional and sentimental and I walk
away feeling how lucky I am to be
associated with the enterprise